what a great audience
happy Friday everybody it's written
right we made it
thank you for being here we love having
you we are back with our live uh studio
audience by the way coming up tonight
right here in studio Congressman Jim
Jordan of Ohio will be here also we have
our all right you're doing a great job
along with our great great great
American panel later more explosive
whistleblower testimony about how our
doj has been weaponized also uh AOC is
having a little bit of trouble she might
be in legal trouble we'll explain
straight ahead and I may even shock you
and defend her
hold on you don't know what I'm gonna do
yet stay tuned all right but first Joe
Biden well he is continuing to keep keep
us all in suspense and waiting take a
look
thank you
[Music]
I don't think he knows it's Friday
um now the 80 year old sitting president
just won't say whether he plans to run
for a second term although his wife Jill
said it for him that does not exactly
Inspire any confidence in me but if he
ultimately does decide to run it looks
like it'll be back to the basement
bunker for Joey who is reportedly now
enlisting prominent Democrats to travel
and speak on his behalf because he's
likely not capable look at this number
already 68 of you the American people
think that Joe is way too old to run for
reelection and in a poll released only
last month 16. that's it only 16 percent
said that they were better off
financially under Joe Biden now remember
with or without Biden the 2024 election
is well underway let's take a look
[Music]
[Applause]
Donald Trump just released that ad now
he did announce his bid last November we
also have Nikki Haley uh we have uh the
vague
ramaswamy who's running a few others are
officially in the race look for Senator
Tim Scott former VP Mike Pence a former
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo possibly
Virginia governor Glenn Younkin Larry
Hogan Florida Governor Ronda Santos
Chris Christie New Hampshire Governor
sununu all possible contenders and we
will know by this time next year who's
likely to get the nomination anyway both
the Santos and Trump are poised to visit
Iowa this month that is the site of the
first Republican caucus in multiple
polls now the duo are leading one and
two the Republican field with Trump as
the latest Fox News poll in first place
and while Republicans are moving full
steam ahead Democrats say are in
complete disarray now with Joe Biden's
approval rating underwater he is in deep
trouble and by the way uh seeking a
second term is not exciting pretty much
anybody but as they say you can't teach
an old dog you're dying what was it a
lying dog face Pony show something I
forgot
yeah exactly uh you can't teach an old
dog new tricks but despite his tanking
poll numbers Biden is doubling and
tripling down on his awful policies new
today and accidentally leaked internal
Memo from the administration showing
that Biden is prioritizing once again
climate considerations over quote
greater energy security wow that
compromises our national security
remember oil gas coal is the lifeblood
of our economy period end of sentence
and also new today he announced another
Aid package to Ukraine this time another
400 million of your dollars now Biden
refuses to allow Ukraine to have
sophisticated uh warplanes that has been
offered by other European countries uh
that would put them on in parody with
Vladimir Putin and could possibly
hopefully end the war war quickly
instead he's funding what is now
becoming a deadly Quagmire all at your
expense even saying this war may go on
three more years from today now clearly
we have not learned from Iraq or
Afghanistan and Joe Biden is clearly not
fighting or allowing the ukrainians to
fight and win he's not allowing Ukraine
to fight and win and Europe is now
paying next to nothing compared to the
American taxpayers now if you're not
going to fight a war to win the war stop
wasting the American taxpayers dollars
now right
if you're gonna fight fight to win
Donald Trump beat the caliphate because
he fought to win and he bombed the
living hell out of them and he did win
the war but the right it worked but the
Reckless spending doesn't stop there Joe
continues to push his very
unconstitutional plan to pay off student
loans with your hard-earned tax dollars
don't you love this idea you Empower
your government to take other people's
money to pay for a loan that you signed
your name on that you said you would pay
back why should someone else have to pay
back your loan anyway it's so bad that
even the Washington Post they will
forced to question the plan's legality
and meanwhile his own party is now
turning against them house Democrats
feel betrayed by his apparent flip-flop
on the D.C crime bill which would
significantly reduce penalties for
violent criminals AOC publicly
criticized Biden over his change of
heart to her millions of Twitter
followers and privately it's even worse
first because according to one house
Democrat quote hundreds of his
colleagues are panicking over the
prospect of a weak frail cognitive mess
who will be 82 years old if he runs
again but even as the crisis pile up
well Joe is once again off to Delaware
for the weekend of course he is for much
needed R and R but we don't know and
won't know who he's going to be meeting
we never know that question an answer to
that question anyway and that brings us
to the Biden blunders of the week you're
going to love it
[Applause]
yeah
[Music]
uh by the way there's an awful lot of
really good Republicans the Maggie
Republicans are a different breed of cat
no right they're not bad or good Edition
very they're very different and by the
way you know I'm not I I may be a white
boy but I'm not stupid but I'm not
joking if they have to pay out 150 159
000 billion dollars less
less
you think I'm joking I want to make it
clear I'm going to raise some taxes I'm
going to raise some taxes
[Music]
you think I'm joking I'm not and I had a
nurse named Pearl Nelson military
she'd come in and do things that I don't
think can learn the medical school
nursing school
she'd whisper in my ear I didn't
couldn't understand him she wished when
she'd leaned down
it actually breathed on me to make look
folks
anyway how do we get started
that's your president now when Biden
wasn't mumbling bumbling stumbling
around this week he was laughing about
children dying from fentanyl take a look
at this shocking and frankly disgusting
video take a look
a little bit of more Marjorie teller
green and a few more you're going to
have a lottery problems running our way
I was the reason she was she was very
specific I shouldn't aggress problems
I've read
she she was very specific recently
saying that a mom a poor mother who lost
two kids to Fentanyl that that I killed
her sons
well the interesting thing is that
fentanyl they took came during the last
Administration
look folks
anyway I don't want to get started
can't help himself hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else